anyway to present the first to work for
75 we've called in the scene-stealer who
won her first Oscar in 74 veteran that
she is she's going to honor some actors
who appeared and films with her
these are filmed that she couldn't see
without parental guidance to provide the
PG tonight is her personal leading man
off screen and on so welcome the
O'Neill's Tatum and Ryan
we're here to present the first Oscar of
the evening but before we do
my father has I need to tell you thank
you Tatum let me explain how Academy
winners are selected all eligible
Academy members are asked to vote for
nominations for the best picture of the
year the other nominations are made by
members of each Academy branch for
special committees then all active
Academy members vote by secret ballot
for all the awards of merit and
furnished their ballots for the
Academy's independent accountants for
tabulation
Documentary short subjects and short
films are the sole exceptions only
active members who attend special
screenings may vote for them results are
known only to Price Waterhouse and
company until the sealed envelopes are
opened here before you thank you daddy
now let's see what's in those envelopes
uh yeah well seeing how you won last
year Tatum you tell the lucky man who he
is let's see let's uh let's see who the
nominees are
the Best Supporting Actor in his role
Fred Astaire in the towering inferno
Jeff Bridges and thunderbolt and
Lightfoot Robert De Niro in The
Godfather Part two Michael v Gossow in
The Godfather Part two Lee Strasberg in
the Godfather Part two you do it
the winner is Robert in Iran the guy
producer-director the gunpowder party
mr. Francis Ford Coppola
well I'm happy that one of my one of my
boys made it I think I think this is a
very richly deserved award I think
Robert De Niro is an extraordinary actor
and he is going to enrich the film films
that are made for years to come
and I thank you on his behalf